This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Funny. What was the last time you baked a cake? Last week here. When American food companies introduced cake mixes in the 1930s, they figured they had a winner. All you had to do was add water to the mix and pop it into the oven.
这里是Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。有趣。你上一次烤蛋糕是什么时候？上周在这里。20世纪30年代，当美国食品公司推出蛋糕预拌粉时，他们觉得自己成功了。你只需要在混合粉中加水，然后放进烤箱。
You don't have to be an expert when you use my cake mix. The man really goes for it. There was just one problem. American women were not going for it. Sales lagged for nearly two decades. Northwestern University researcher Lauren Nordgren says the lack of interest wasn't because the cake's tasted bad. The problem was psychological.
用我的蛋糕预拌粉，你不需要成为专家。这个人真的很拼。只有一个问题。美国女性并不买账。销量滞后了近二十年。西北大学研究员劳伦·诺德格伦表示，缺乏兴趣并不是因为蛋糕味道不好。问题是心理上的。
What baking a cake represents is care. And the perception was, was that making cake with a pre-packaged mix was a violation of that act. General Mills hired a psychologist named Ernest Dictor, who came up with a clever solution. Instead of including dried eggs in their mixes, General Mills asked bakers to add fresh eggs. When you make a cake from a mix, which do you want? A fresh egg cake or a cake made with dried eggs? Why fresh eggs, of course? Cracking eggs and whisking them into the mix gave Bakers the sense that that cake was homemade. Sales of the mixes took off.
烤蛋糕代表着关心。人们的看法是，用预拌粉做蛋糕是对这种行为的违背。通用磨坊聘请了一位名叫欧内斯特·迪克特的心理学家，他想出了一个巧妙的解决方案。通用磨坊没有在预拌粉中加入干鸡蛋，而是要求烘焙者加入新鲜鸡蛋。当你用预拌粉做蛋糕时，你想要哪个？新鲜鸡蛋蛋糕还是用干鸡蛋做的蛋糕？当然是新鲜鸡蛋了！打碎鸡蛋并将它们搅拌到面团中，让烘焙者产生一种蛋糕是自制的错觉。预拌粉的销量腾飞了。
A perfect cake. You be the judge or write General Mills Minneapolis Minnesota and get your money back. This week on Hidden Brain, we continue our success 2.0 series with a look at a core component of innovation, seeing things from the perspectives of other people. Many organizations struggle to gain traction in a crowded marketplace. They can decide should they invest in more marketing, better products or hiring. At Northwestern University's Kellogg School of Management, psychologist Lauren Nordgren says all those things are important,
完美的蛋糕。你来评判，或者写信给明尼苏达州明尼阿波利斯的通用磨坊并拿回你的钱。本周的Hidden Brain节目中，我们继续“成功2.0”系列，探讨创新的核心组成部分——从他人的角度看待事物。许多组织在拥挤的市场中努力获得关注。他们可以决定是应该投资于更多的营销、更好的产品还是招聘。西北大学凯洛格管理学院的心理学家劳伦·诺德格伦表示，所有这些事情都很重要，
but very often they fail to move the needle. That's because most organizations focus on the things that can move them forward instead of the things that hold them back. Lauren Nordgren, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much. I am honored to be here. I want to start by understanding the nature of the problem you've been studying for a while, Lauren. You have a wonderful example of a Chicago-based furniture company. You call this company Beach House. That's not the real name of the company. But can you tell me what they were selling and what their sales pitch was?
但它们往往无法扭转局面。这是因为大多数组织关注的是能够推动他们前进的事情，而不是阻碍他们的事情. 劳伦·诺德格伦，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。非常感谢。我很荣幸来到这里。我想先了解一下你一直在研究的问题的本质，劳伦。你有一个很好的例子，关于一家总部位于芝加哥的家具公司。你把这家公司叫做“海滩屋”。这不是公司的真名。但你能告诉我们他们卖的是什么，他们的销售宣传是什么吗？
Beach House makes fully customizable sofas and chairs. And the promise is that you end up with a one-of-a-kind piece of furniture, almost something like your own art. And their target audience is young millennials. This is often their first piece of adult furniture. And they love the idea and they love the process of creation. So whether they would go into the design showroom,
“海滩屋”生产完全可定制的沙发和椅子。其承诺是，你最终会得到一件独一无二的家具，几乎就像你自己的艺术品。他们的目标受众是年轻的千禧一代。这通常是他们买的第一件成人家具。他们喜欢这个想法，也喜欢创作的过程。所以无论他们是走进设计展厅，
whether they would do it online, people would spend hours designing the perfect sofa for them. Now people clearly like the idea. They were coming in spending hours designing the sofa as they want. It's done. But that turned out to not be the full story because something happened before they could make the sale. What happened, Laura? These would be customers disappeared. Now in Beach House's mind, their thought was, well, perhaps we need to reduce price further, thereby making our product more attractive. Maybe we need a better
还是在网上操作，人们都会花上几个小时为自己设计完美的沙发。现在人们显然很喜欢这个想法。他们进来花几个小时设计他们想要的沙发。完成了。但事实证明，这并不是全部，因为在他们完成销售之前发生了一些事情。发生了什么，劳伦？这些潜在客户消失了。在“海滩屋”看来，他们的想法是，嗯，也许我们需要进一步降价，从而使我们的产品更具吸引力。也许我们需要更好的
customer experience, so we should invest in that training. Maybe we need to create higher quality fabrics and materials. Maybe that's how we make the idea more attractive. In many ways, this is so intuitive. If you're a company that finds that people are not buying your product, you know, if you want to grow, if you want more customers, you say, I need to improve my product. I will give them a better deal or market yourself better. Now beach hours eventually figured out why that potential customers were not completing
客户体验，所以我们应该投资于培训。也许我们需要创造更高质量的面料和材料。也许这就是我们让这个想法更具吸引力的方法。在许多方面，这是非常直观的。如果你是一家发现人们不买你产品的公司，你知道的，如果你想成长，如果你想要更多的客户，你会说，我需要改进我的产品。我会给他们更好的交易或更好地进行营销。现在，“海滩屋”终于弄清楚了为什么潜在客户没有完成
the sale. They brought in a colleague of yours, David Schoenfeld, to try and understand the problem. What did he discover? And how did they fix the problem, what did he discover and how did they fix the problem? Lauren. David Schoenfall did what we might call an ethnography, a deep dive into the needs and backgrounds of these disappearing customers. And one idea came up again and again and it was people didn't know what to do with their existing sofa. Think about it. It's not as if they were just sitting on the floor.
购买。他们请来了你的同事大卫·舍恩菲尔德来试图了解这个问题。他发现了什么？他们是如何解决这个问题的，他发现了什么，他们是如何解决这个问题的？劳伦。大卫·舍恩菲尔德做了我们所谓的民族志研究，深入研究了这些消失的客户的需求和背景。有一个想法一次又一次地出现，那就是人们不知道如何处理他们现有的沙发。想想看。好像他们只是坐在地板上一样。
They have an existing sofa. They have an existing chair. And they loved what Beach House had to offer, but at some point, it occurred to them that they cannot move forward with this thing they want to do until they figure out what to do with their current sofa because they can't have two. So the questions would be things like, can I physically move it?
他们有一个现成的沙发。他们有一把现成的椅子。他们喜欢“海滩屋”所提供的东西，但在某个时刻，他们发现，在他们弄清楚如何处理当前的沙发之前，他们无法推进他们想要做的事情，因为他们不能有两个沙发。所以问题通常是这样的：我能把它搬走吗？
And if I can, do I just take it out to the trash or is there some special day or some special service? Do I trust that the city of Chicago is going to be efficient in providing that service, et cetera? Hmm. How did beach hours go about addressing the challenge once they discovered what the problem was? The solution was to offer to pick up existing sofas upon delivery. And the moment that offer was made, that conversion problem, that disappearing customer
如果可以，我是把它扔到垃圾堆里，还是有什么特殊的日子或特殊的服务？我信任芝加哥市政府能够高效地提供这种服务吗，等等？嗯。一旦发现问题所在，“海滩屋”是如何着手解决这一挑战的？解决方案是在交付时提供旧沙发回收服务。而一旦做出这个承诺，转化问题、那个“消失的客户”的
conundrum largely evaporated. The lesson of the story is that beach house didn't need to push harder to make the sale. It didn't need to lower prices. It didn't need to change its business model. Customers were already sold on all those things. What it needed to do was remove a hidden impediment that was keeping customers from completing the purchase. Lauren says the same principle applies in the non-profit world. Organizations trying to help people often think they need to market themselves better or sell their vision more strongly.
难题就基本烟消云散了。这个故事的教训是，“海滩屋”不需要更用力地推销来达成交易。它不需要降价。它不需要改变其商业模式。客户已经对所有这些事情买账了。它需要做的是消除阻碍客户完成购买的隐藏障碍。劳伦说，同样的原则也适用于非营利世界。试图帮助人们的组织常常认为他们需要更好地进行营销或更有力地推销他们的愿景。
You're bringing to mind one of the powerful stories that we think about, which comes from a woman by the name of Stacey Alonzo. And she was working at a shelter called Shade Tree for women and children who've experienced domestic abuse and homelessness. And she would have this similar experience to the beach house case where, again and again, she would see women pull up to the shelter, stare at the shelter for minutes or hours. Sometimes they would even walk all the way up to the door and at the last second, they would even walk all the way up to the door and at the last second they would turn away.
你让我想起了一个我们常想到的有力故事，它来自一个叫斯黛西·阿隆佐的女性。她曾在一家名为“浓荫树”的庇护所工作，服务对象是遭受家庭暴力和无家可归的妇女儿童。她会遇到与“海滩屋”案例类似的经历，她一次又一次地看到妇女把车开到庇护所前，盯着庇护所看几分钟或几小时。有时她们甚至会一直走到门口，而在最后一秒，她们甚至会走到门口，在最后一秒钟，
And the question is why would they turn away? And she discovered what they were seeing is a sign on the door that said no pets allowed. So if you are in a difficult domestic relationship, the benefits of escaping that relationship are often very clear. What was holding people back is this realization, this strong emotional sense that I simply cannot leave a pet behind. So the way they solve this problem and in such a beautiful story is she created what's called Noah's Animal
她们又转身离开了。问题是，她们为什么要转身离开？她发现她们看到的是门上写着“谢绝宠物”的牌子。因此，如果你身处一段艰难的家庭关系中，逃离这段关系的益处通常是非常清晰的。阻碍人们的是这种认识，这种强烈的情感意识：我根本无法抛弃宠物。因此，他们解决这个问题的方式——这是一个非常美丽的故事——是她创建了所谓的“诺亚动物
House, which is a facility that allows women to shelter their pets close by on the grounds of the shelter itself. So in each of these examples, Lauren, if you don't study what's holding people back, it can seem as if there's some kind of invisible force that's demotivating people and keeping them from taking action. So our stock response in these situations is to push people harder to add carrots or sticks or what you call fuel. You say a better approach is to understand the source of what's holding people back to understand the source of the friction. Can you talk about the contrast that you're drawing
之家”，这是一个允许女性将宠物安置在庇护所范围内的设施。因此，在这些例子中，劳伦，如果你不去研究是什么阻碍了人们，看起来就好像有一种无形的力在消磨人们的动力，阻止他们采取行动。因此，我们在这些情况下的默认反应是更用力地推动人们，增加胡萝卜加大棒，或者你所谓的“燃料”。你说更好的方法是了解阻碍人们的根源，了解摩擦的根源。你能谈谈你在
between fuel and friction? Uh-huh. The job of fuel is to elevate and enhance the appeal of an idea. So using incentives, using an emotional appeal, giving data evidence, all of that is designed to demonstrate the value of the new idea and initiative. Friction is the psychological force
燃料和摩擦之间划出的对比吗？嗯哼。燃料的作用是提升和增强一个想法的吸引力。因此，使用激励措施、使用情感诉求、提供数据证据，所有这些都是为了证明新想法和新倡议的价值。摩擦是心理力量
or the set of forces that resist change. Now, frictions take different forms and we often don't see them, we often don't talk about them, but in essence, frictions act as drag on innovation and change. So we're going to talk about the different forms that friction can take in ways to overcome it, but I want to start by laying out in some ways why it is organizations and individuals tend to focus on the fuel component of the equation rather than on friction.
或抵抗改变的一组力量。现在，摩擦有不同的形式，我们往往看不到它们，我们往往不谈论它们，但本质上，摩擦就像是创新和改变的阻力。所以我们要讨论摩擦可以采取的不同形式以及克服它的方法，但我想首先从某种程度上阐述为什么组织和个人倾向于关注方程式中的燃料部分，而不是摩擦。
And I was thinking about trying to launch a spaceship into orbit, for example, it does seem tempting to focus on building a bigger rocket instead of designing a lighter spaceship. Why do you think that is, Laura? It's because we naturally understand behavior in terms of internal forces, things like motivation and intent, understanding behavior, interpreting it in terms of these internal forces, like motivation and
比如，我一直在想试图将宇宙发射到轨道上的事，专注于建造一个更大的火箭，而不是设计一个更轻的飞船，确实很诱人。你认为这是为什么，劳伦？这是因为我们自然而然地根据内部力量（如动机和意图）来理解行为，理解行为，并根据这些内部力量（如动机和意图）来解释行为，
intent, perfectly maps on to fuel. So you're trying to launch a new product and maybe people aren't buying. The way the mind understands that is to assume that it's because the appeal, the allure, is insufficient. And if that's the problem you imagine, the way you solve that problem is to elevate appeal and fuel does that job. I'm wondering if it's also possible to go back to my analogy of the spaceship. Should you build a bigger rocket or should you build a lighter spaceship? It's also, in some way, sexier to build a bigger rocket. Designing a lighter spaceship means doing a vast number of things that are more humble,
这与燃料完全契合。所以你正试图推出一个新产品，也许人们不买。大脑理解这一点的方式是假设这是因为吸引力和魅力不足。如果你想象的问题是这个，你解决问题的方法就是提升吸引力，而燃料就能起到这个作用。我想知道是否也可以回到我关于宇宙飞船的比喻。你应该建造一个更大的火箭，还是应该建造一个更轻的飞船？从某种程度上讲，建造一个更大的火箭也更性感。设计一台更轻的飞船意味着要做大量更卑微的事情，
designing lighter materials, lighter technology. If you have astronauts on board, you want lighter plates and cups, so maybe even lighter clothing. I'm wondering if one reason it's easier to focus on building a bigger rocket is because friction can be caused by so many different things. And in some ways it's easier and sexier to think about the big solution rather than the myriad small solutions. Absolutely. Friction requires discovery. Friction tends to require that we shift attention from the idea itself, which is our natural point of fixation, and instead start to consider the audience. The broader contextual emotional needs of the audience. So frictions tend to be buried and therefore require discovery.
设计更轻的材料、更轻的技术。如果船上有宇航员，你需要更轻的盘子和杯子，甚至可能是更轻的服装。我想知道，专注于建造更大的火箭之所以更容易，原因之一是否是因为摩擦可以由许多不同的事情引起？在某种程度上，思考宏大的解决方案比思考无数微小的解决方案更容易、也更性感。绝对的。摩擦需要发现。摩擦往往要求我们将注意力从创意本身（这是我们天然的焦点）转移开，转而开始考虑受众。受众更广泛的语境情感需求。因此，摩擦往往被埋藏起来，因此需要被发现。
They require knowing our audience and knowing the context. It's really hard to remember that people don't engage with us for our reasons. They engage with us for their reasons. So we think we're selling a great sofa, surely that's what matters. From the customer's point of view, the hassle of getting rid of their old sofa matters as much, maybe more than the beauty of our sofas. Absolutely right. Finding, uncovering, friction requires perspective taking and knowing your audience. The problem goes even deeper. It's not just that we need to pay attention to both fuel and friction. Sometimes, fuel creates additional friction.
它们需要了解我们的受众和语境。真的很难记住，人们不是为了我们的原因而与我们互动的。他们是为了他们自己的原因与我们互动。所以我们认为我们卖的是一张好沙发，这当然重要。从客户的角度来看，处理旧沙发的麻烦同样重要，甚至可能比我们沙发的美丽更重要。完全正确。发现、揭示摩擦需要视角转换和了解你的受众。问题甚至更深。不仅仅是我们需要同时关注燃料和摩擦。有时，燃料会产生额外的摩擦。
Lauren told me about one effort that tried to dissuade men from writing graffiti on the walls of a public bathroom. One message was a low fuel message. The other made a stronger sales pitch. It applied more fuel. So there were two versions that are roughly like one is, please do not write on the bathroom wall, and the other was much stronger where it was, in essence, under no circumstance, should you write on the bathroom wall. And not surprisingly, the one that had the stronger message produced the greatest backlash. And in some ways that speaks to what you were saying a second ago,
劳伦告诉我一个试图劝阻男性在公共浴室墙壁上乱涂乱画的努力。一条信息是低燃料信息。另一条则做了更强有力的销售宣传。它应用了更多的燃料。所以有两个版本，大致类似于一个是，请不要在浴室墙上乱涂乱画，另一个则强得多，本质上是，在任何情况下，你都不应该在浴室墙上乱涂乱画。毫不奇怪，拥有更强烈信息的那个版本产生了最大的强烈反对。从某种程度上说，这说明了你刚才所说的一点，
which is that our stock response of using fuel as the way to get what we want, we sometimes fail to see that in some ways it can produce its own resistance. Yes, this is the folly of fuel. So if you think about when we push on people, their instinct is to push back. So you see that fuel doesn't move the people who are open to change,
那就是我们用燃料作为得到我们想要的东西的默认反应，有时我们没有看到，在某些情况下，它会产生它自己的阻力。是的，这就是燃料的愚蠢之处。所以如果你想想当我们对人们施压时，他们的本能就是推回。所以你会看到燃料并不能打动对改变持开放态度的人，
and it often makes things worse for those who reject the message. Even the best ideas and organizations can face resistance. Motivational messages can backfire. Perfectly polite signs can make people more prone to bad behavior. When we come back, the different kinds of friction we confront in the workplace and in our relationships, and techniques to fight them. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
而对于那些拒绝这一信息的人来说，它往往会使情况变得更糟糕。即使是最好的想法和组织也可能面临阻力。激励信息可能会适得其反。完全礼貌的标志可能会让人更容易产生不良行为。当我们回来时，我们将探讨我们在工作场所和人际关系中面临的不同种类的摩擦，以及对抗它们的技巧。你正在收听的是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We've seen how it often takes more than a good idea to make something a success. All around us, there are hidden forces making it difficult to reach our goals, close a sale, or convince others to adopt new ideas. When organizations meet resistance, all too often, they focus on adding fuel, building better products, selling harder or marketing better. There's nothing inherently wrong with that, but there is something many organizations fail
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们已经看到，要让某事取得成功，往往需要的不仅仅是一个好想法。在我们周围，有各种隐藏的力量使得实现我们的目标、达成交易或说服他人采纳新想法变得困难。当组织遇到阻力时，往往会把重点放在添加燃料、制造更好的产品、更大力度地推销或更好地进行营销上。这本身并没有什么错，但许多组织没有做到的一点是
to do. They don't ask how they can subtract friction, how they can remove the obstacles that allow their audiences, customers and clients to fully engage with them. In their book, The Human Element overcoming the resistance that awaits new ideas, Lauren Nordgren and David Schonthel, both professors at the Kellogg School of Management at Northwest on University, say that part of the problem is that friction comes in many disguises. We often fail to dismantle it because we simply don't see it. Lauren, you tell a story about the University of Chicago. It's one of the best schools in the world, but for years the university had inexplicably low applications from prospective
。他们没有问自己如何才能减少摩擦，如何才能消除障碍，让受众、客户和消费者能够完全与他们互动。在他们的书《人性元素：克服等待新想法的阻力》中，西北大学凯洛格管理学院的教授劳伦·诺德格伦和大卫·舍恩菲尔德表示，部分问题在于摩擦有许多伪装。我们经常无法拆除它，因为我们根本看不到它。劳伦，你讲了一个关于芝加哥大学的故事。它是世界上最好的学校之一，但多年来，该校的潜在申请人数却莫名其妙地少。
students. So in 2005, for example, Princeton had 28,000 applications, Chicago had fewer than 4,000. And initially you say many people at the university believed it was because their school was more rigorous and that this was what was discouraging applicants. The unofficial motto of the University of Chicago is where fun goes to die part of its culture. It is a place of rigor. And the belief was that that rigor, that reputation, kept people away.
因此，例如在2005年，普林斯顿大学有28,000份申请，而芝加哥大学则不到4,000份。起初你说，大学里的许多人认为这是因为他们的学校更严谨，正是这一点吓退了申请者。芝加哥大学非官方的座右铭是“乐趣去哪里消亡”，这是其文化的一部分。这是一个严谨的地方。人们认为，这种严谨、这种声誉把人们挡在了门外。
Well, it turns out the rigor of University of Chicago at that time was not the only thing that set it apart. Most schools today, when you apply to a college, you fill out some forms, and then you can distribute those applications to dozens of schools. University of Chicago required a customized essay, and often it is a wild, outlandish essay that would require you to write a completely tailored application. And from an economist, I suppose you would say, given that both the prestige of the school and the low application rate, the day or two that is required for you to write this application
嗯，事实证明，芝加哥大学当时的严谨并不是唯一让它与众不同的地方。如今大多数学校，当你申请大学时，你填写一些表格，然后你可以将这些申请分发给十几所学校。而芝加哥大学要求一篇定制的论文，而且通常是一篇狂野、古怪的论文，需要你写一份完全量身定制的申请。从经济学家的角度来看，我想你会说，鉴于学校的声望和较低的申请率，写这篇申请所需的一天或两天时间是一笔值得的投资。但在几年前，学校做出了一个有争议的决定，放弃了非常规申请表格，开始使用竞争学校使用的相同系统。而就在那一刻，申请量急剧飙升。
is a worthwhile investment. But a few years back, a controversial decision was made to drop the uncommon app and to start using the same system their competing schools use. And the moment that happened, applications went through the roof. And that speaks to a really essential idea of friction. It's that we tend to dramatically underestimate the power of these frictions. Often small changes
这说明了关于摩擦的一个非常核心的观念。那就是我们往往大大低估了这些摩擦的力量。通常，微小的改变
can have such a dramatic impact on behavior. I want to spend a moment talking about a few other examples of this idea that people really prefer the path of least resistance. You cite research that shows that in many workplaces, people choose their friends based on where their friends are sitting. And that most people form close relationships in the workplace with other people who are within 160 feet of them.
可以对行为产生如此戏剧性的影响。我想花点时间谈谈这个观点的其他几个例子，即人们确实更喜欢阻力最小的路径。你引用了一项研究，表明在许多工作场所，人们根据朋友的座位来选择朋友。大多数人在工作场所与距离他们160英尺以内的人建立密切关系。
Now, obviously, we spend more time with the people who are sitting around us. Maybe those people are part of our teams. We get to work with them more often. But it's telling that something as simple as workplace geography can end up shaping personal relationships. It's often referred to as the proximity principle, and one dimension of effort is ease of interaction. And this was one of my first experiences in understanding the power of friction
现在，很明显，我们和坐在我们周围的人花更多的时间。也许这些人是我们团队的一部分。我们有更多机会和他们一起工作。但说明问题的是，像工作场所地理位置这样简单的事情竟然能塑造人际关系。这通常被称为“邻近原则”，而努力的一个维度是交互的简便性。这也是我作为研究生时对理解摩擦力的力量的最初体验之一。
as a graduate student. There were two departments on the same floor. And although we were two departments, it felt like one department lunches together, table tennis tournaments, coffee, beers, after work, a lot of camaraderie. And then one department moved up two floors. Now, it occurred to no one that this would change the dynamics. In fact, we were all happy that we were getting more
同一层楼有两个部门。尽管我们是两个部门，但感觉就像一个部门：一起吃午餐、乒乓球赛、咖啡、下班后的啤酒，有很多友情。然后一个部门搬到了上面两层。现在，谁也没想到这会改变动态。事实上，我们都很高兴能获得更多
space. But what happened? Those relationships, those interactions, it was like night or day. The only time you would see these people that you once saw with great regularity was this kind of awkward moment in the elevator where it really revealed what was the depth of this relationship. Well, apparently it's not stronger than two flights of stairs. Wow. So, we've seen that following the path of least resistance in some ways is the first friction that we have to contend with.
空间。但是发生了什么？那些关系、那些互动，简直就像黑夜和白天一样。唯一能见到这些你曾经经常见到的人的时刻，就是电梯里的那种尴尬时刻，这真正展现了这段关系的深度。好吧，显然它经不起两层楼梯的考验。哇。所以，我们已经看到，顺从阻力最小的路径在某种程度上是我们必须应对的第一种摩擦。
It turns out there are at least three other kinds of friction. And one of those, Lauren, is the issue of inertia. Much of the time when we review something, a new change, a new proposal, a new product, we're often comparing it to what we have to the status quo. Can you talk about the role that inertia plays in holding organizations and communities back from change? Yeah, the human mind reflexively favors the familiar over the unfamiliar, even when the benefits of the unfamiliar option are indisputable.
事实证明，至少还有另外三种摩擦。其中之一，劳伦，就是惯性问题。很多时候，当我们审查某事、一个新的改变、一个新的提案、一个新产品时，我们经常把它与我们现有的东西、现状进行比较。你能谈谈惯性在阻碍组织和社区进行变革方面所起的作用吗？是的，人类的大脑本能地偏爱熟悉的事物而不是不熟悉的事物，即使不熟悉选项的好处是无可争议的。
And we tend to favor the system we are in over better new ways of doing things. And this inertia tends to be greatest when we are pursuing big radical change. If we think of the kinds of change that we are most hungry for, whether that's societal or leaps in innovation. The problem is the greater the change, often the more resistance people have because that unfamiliarity is an inherent friction. It creates resistance and reluctance in the mind. If you've suggested a new idea at work and watched it get shot down because it's too
而且我们往往偏爱我们身处其中的系统，而不是更好的做事新方法。当我们追求巨大、激进的变革时，这种惯性往往最大。如果我们想想我们最渴望的那种变革，无论是社会变革还是创新飞跃。问题在于，变革越大，人们受到的阻力往往就越大，因为这种不熟悉感是一种固有的摩擦。它在头脑中产生阻力和不情愿。如果你在工作中提出了一个新想法，却眼睁睁看着它因过于
novel, you've just encountered the friction of inertia. If your company has come out with a new product and customers rejected out of hand because it seems unfamiliar, that could be the result of inertia too. The third form of friction is related to the first two. People don't just pursue the path of least resistance when it comes to things involving effort. They pursue the path of least resistance when it comes to their emotions. Lauren cites the example of a challenge faced by US Army recruiters.
新颖而被枪毙，你刚刚遇到了惯性的摩擦。如果你的公司推出了一款新产品，而客户因为觉得面生而直接拒绝，这可能也是惯性的结果。第三种形式的摩擦与前两种有关。当涉及需要付出努力的事情时，人们不仅会追求阻力最小的路径。当涉及他们的情感时，他们也会追求阻力最小的路径。劳伦举了一个美国陆军招募人员面临的挑战的例子。
Much like the beach house case, Army recruiters want more recruits, they want better recruits, and they're mostly targeting junior seniors in high school. And very often you see these people who are excited by the idea and Army life for the right person is heavily fueled. There's patriotism, so meaning, camaraderie, connection, professional advancement opportunities. You see these people who are clearly intrigued, excited by the idea, but many of them,
就像“海滩屋”的案例一样，陆军招聘人员想要更多的兵源，想要更好的新兵，他们主要的目标是高中三年级和四年级的学生。你经常会看到这些人对这个想法感到兴奋，对于合适的人来说，军队生活充满了动力。有爱国主义，所以有意义、情谊、联系、职业发展机会。你看到这些人显然被这个想法深深吸引、兴奋不已，但他们中的许多人，
a significant proportion of them, never enlist. And a reason why is because they're afraid to tell mom and dad. And for many of them, it's the anxiety is because they're afraid to tell mom and dad. And for many of them, it's the anxiety around what parents will say, how they'll respond, that leads them to simply never follow their dream. Now, you can try to push harder on the idea of joining the army. This is the fuel-based approach. But remember, the people the Army wanted to persuade
很大一部分人，从未参军。原因之一是因为他们害怕告诉爸爸妈妈。对他们中的许多人来说，焦虑是因为害怕告诉爸爸妈妈。对他们中的许多人来说，对父母会说什、会如何反应的焦虑，导致他们根本不敢去追逐自己的梦想。现在，你可以尝试更用力地推销参军的想法。这就是基于燃料的方法。但请记住，陆军想要说服的人
were already sold on the idea. That wasn't what was holding them back. Lauren says the Army came up with a different approach to reduce emotional friction. The Army recruiter has scripts that can help the student have that conversation. And, anecdotally, we've heard cases of recruiters who will even volunteer to have that conversation. And, anecdotally, we've heard cases of recruiters who will even volunteer to have that conversation
已经对这个想法买账了。那并不是阻碍他们的原因。劳伦说，陆军想出了一种不同的方法来减少情感摩擦。陆军招聘人员有脚本可以帮助学生进行那次对话。而且，根据轶事，我们听说过这样的案例：招聘人员甚至会自愿进行那次对话，
or be in the room when that conversation takes place. Hmm. So people experience emotional friction, even when it comes to doing things that they're highly motivated to do. And in this case, I want to talk about the idea of dating. Many people sign up for dating websites, but then drop out because they
或者在对话进行时留在房间里。嗯。所以人们会经历情感摩擦，即使是在做那些他们有极高动力去做的事情时。在这种情况下，我想谈谈约会的话题。许多人注册了约会网站，但随后又退出了，因为他们
find the process to be emotionally draining. Can you talk about this idea and how some companies have tried to find ways around this particular form of friction? A great story around emotional friction is thinking about the emergence of online dating, the first generation platforms, So the emergence of online dating, the first generation platforms, for example, match.com, and the second wave, Tinder being the best example. And Tinder, specifically that second wave, quickly became the dominant model. And a reason for that is because Tinder could spot a friction that was embedded in the first generation website. So when you talk to people on say match.com, there are emotional frictions embedded in the first generation website. So when you talk to people on say match.com,
发现这个过程在情感上令人精疲力竭。你能谈谈这个想法以及一些公司是如何试图找到绕过这种特定形式摩擦的方法的吗？一个关于情感摩擦的伟大故事是思考在线约会的兴起，第一代平台，例如match.com，以及第二代，Tinder是最好的例子。而Tinder，特别是第二代，迅速成为主导模式。原因之一是Tinder能够发现嵌入在第一代网站中的摩擦。所以当你和像match.com这样的人交谈时，嵌入在第一代网站中的情感摩擦。所以当你和像match.com这样的人交谈时，
there are emotional frictions embedded in that process. There are several, but a big one is rejection. Right. So imagine you find the person, the person that checks every box. This could be the one. So now what do you have to do, you have to craft the perfect email, funny, but not too funny, serious, but not too serious, etc. That is its own form of effort, that other friction. But now you write the perfect email, you've made your friends look at it, etc. You send it off and what happens? Well, people here respond like you're too short, you're not in my age range, I don't date Republicans, or worse of all, you don't hear anything at all.
这个过程中存在着情感摩擦。有几个，但其中一个很大的障碍是拒绝。对。所以想象一下，你找到了那个人，那个符合所有条件的人。这可能就是那个人。现在你必须做什么，你必须精心制作一封完美的电子邮件，有趣但不要太有趣，严肃但不要太严肃，等等。这本身就是一种努力，另一种摩擦。但现在你写了这封完美的电子邮件，你让你的朋友看过它，等等。你把它发出去了，结果怎么样？嗯，人们的反应就像你太矮了，你不在我的年龄范围内，我不和共和党人约会，或者最糟糕的是，你根本听不到任何回音。
And so seeing that, Tinder came up with a very compelling and elegant friction removal solution, mutual matching. So if you're familiar with the Tinder platform, you swipe on people you are potentially initially interested in, but you are only matched with people who signal initial interest in you as well. In other words, there isn't this act of putting myself out there only to experience rejection, I'm only paired with people who signal interest with me. We've looked at how I desired to follow the path of least resistance to prefer the status
看到这一点，Tinder提出了一种非常引人注目且优雅的摩擦消除解决方案：相互匹配。如果你熟悉Tinder平台，你会对你最初可能感兴趣的人进行右滑，但你只会与那些对你也表现出初步兴趣的人匹配。换句话说，没有那种“把自己暴露出去却只经历拒绝”的行为，我只和对我表现出兴趣的人配对。我们已经研究了我们如何渴望遵循阻力最小的路径、偏爱现状
quo and to reduce emotional costs, our three forms of friction. You also talk about a fourth way that friction manifests in our lives. You cite the example of mandatory seatbelt laws. In 1984, New York State became the first state to pass a mandatory seatbelt law. Anyone in the front seat of a car had to wear a seatbelt by law. Even though the move would eventually save tens of thousands of lives, many people were initially outraged. I want to play you a clip of Michael Nozzolio. He's a New York State Assemblyman at the time,
并减少情感成本——这是我们的三种摩擦形式。你还谈到了摩擦在我们生活中表现出来的第四种方式。你引进了强制安全带法律的例子。1984年，纽约州成为第一个通过强制安全带法律的州。法律规定，汽车前排的任何人必须系安全带。尽管这一举措最终将拯救数万人的生命，但许多人最初感到愤怒。我想放一段迈克尔·诺齐奥里奥的剪辑给你听。他当时是纽约州议会议员，
discussing the new law. The question here is whether we have the right, whether we have the responsibility, whether we have the judgment to turn to the citizens of this state and be there in 1984. Big brother. Lauren, you call this reactants. Can you explain what you mean by that term?
讨论新法律。这里的问题是我们是否有权利，我们是否有责任，我们是否有判断力去转向这个国家的公民并在1984年介入。老大哥。劳伦，你称之为抗拒（reactance）。你能解释一下你对这个词的理解吗？
Yeah, reactants is the idea, it's the human impulse, to want to push back against change. And it is rooted in our desire for autonomy. Humans like most other animals have a fundamental need to exert control and influence over their environment. Innovation, creating change and influence, is incompatible with that basic human need. Like, what is the innovator in the conventional sense trying to do? They're trying to get them to follow a particular direction. Well, that's a restriction of freedom. And when we feel that freedom being restricted,
是的，抗拒是一种想法，它是人类想要抵制变化的冲动。它扎根于我们对自主权的渴望。人类和大多数其他动物一样，有一种对环境施加控制和影响的基本需求。创新、创造改变和影响力，与这种基本的人类需求是不相容的。比如，传统意义上的创新者在试图做什么？他们试图让人遵循一个特定的方向。嗯，那是对自由的限制。当我们感觉到这种自由受到限制时，
the human impulse is to push back in order to restore this need, to restore our autonomy or control. You have a wonderful analogy in the book about how a bullet is fired from a gun. It has two elements to it. It has both fuel and friction coming to play. But you use this analogy, this metaphor, to sort of talk about the different ways we should think about fuel and friction. Can you take us back to our high school physics days and explain how a bullet actually comes out of a gun and what this has to do with fuel and friction? We've asked thousands of people over the last year what makes a bullet fly and the near
人类的冲动就是反抗，以恢复这种需求，恢复我们的自主权或控制力。你在书中有一个关于子弹如何从枪中发射出来的精彩比喻。它有两个要素。它既有燃料又有摩擦力在起作用。但你用这个比喻，这个隐喻，来谈论我们应该如何看待燃料和摩擦的不同方式。你能带我们回到高中物理时代，解释子弹实际上是如何从枪里出来的，这与燃料和摩擦有什么关系吗？我们在过去的一年里问过成千上万的人是什么让子弹飞起来的，对这个问题的几乎
universal answer to that question is gunpowder. And people say gunpowder because when gunpowder ignites, it expands rapidly, creating tremendous pressure inside the barrel of a gun. And the only way for that pressure to be released is to push the bullet out the end of the barrel. push the bullet out the end of the barrel. So gunpowder isn't the wrong answer to that question, but it is a woefully incomplete answer because anytime a physical object, be it a bullet or an airplane takes flight, there are these two opposing forces at play. There are the forces that propel the object forward, gunpowder or a jet engine, but there are also these forces that oppose progress, namely gravity and wind resistance. The principal obstacle to a bullet is wind resistance,
普遍回答是火药。人们说火药是因为当火药点燃时，它会迅速膨胀，在枪管内部产生巨大的压力。而释放这种压力的唯一方法就是把子弹从枪管末端推出去。把子弹从枪管末端推出去。所以火药并不是这个问题的错误答案，但它是一个极其不完整的答案，因为任何物理物体，无论是子弹还是飞机，在飞行时都有这两种相反的力量在起作用。有推动物体向前移动的力量——火药或喷气发动机，但也有反对这种进展的力量，即重力和风阻。子弹的主要障碍是风阻，
and that is because the faster an object moves, the stronger the resistance or drag. In other words, add more gunpowder, you simply add more drag. So gunpowder explains the initial velocity, but the reason a bullet is able to fly so far and so true is because it's aerodynamic. It has been built to reduce the frictions operating against it and this is a useful metaphor for understanding our tendency to think in fuel rather than friction.
这是因为物体移动得越快，阻力或拖力就越强。换句话说，增加更多的火药，你只会增加更多的阻力。所以火药解释了初速，但子弹之所以能够飞得那么远、那么准，是因为它是流线型的。它的建造是为了减少对其起作用的摩擦，这是理解我们倾向于从燃料而不是摩擦角度思考的有用的隐喻。
You know, I'm a recreational swimmer, Lauren, and I'm also a student of swimming. I think a lot about swimming technique and for a long time, I thought that the way to propel yourself forward in the water was essentially to you know kick harder or to pull harder. And it's only in recent years that I've actually started to realize that paying attention to drag is actually much more important than paying attention to force. I mean, for one thing, drag matters much more than force. The amount of force you need to overcome drag is enormously costly. But if you can be a little bit more aerodynamic or I guess hydrodynamic in the water, you need much less power to actually move you forward. That's the same idea, I think. Yes, and what resonates with me, the story we've heard again and again,
你知道，我是一名休闲游泳者，劳伦，我也是一名游泳学者。我对游泳技术想了很多，很长一段时间里，我认为在水中推进自己的方式本质上就是——你知道的——更用力地踢腿或更用力地划水。直到最近几年，我才真正开始意识到，关注阻力实际上比关注力量重要得多。我的意思是，首先，阻力比力量重要得多。你克服阻力所需的力量代价极其高昂。但如果你在水中能更具空气动力学特征，或者我猜是流体力学特征，你实际上需要更少的动力来推动你前进。我想这是同一个道理。是的，引起我共鸣的是，我们一次又一次听到的故事
is that this is not the first insight, that it takes a lot of intral and error for people to arrive, whether it's swimming or encycling, for them to come to appreciate how critical friction is and how costly trying to improve performance just through more exertion, more fuel, really is. We've seen the different ways friction can hold back organizations, communities and governments from achieving their goals. We've also seen that pushing harder can sometimes not just be ineffective, but actually counterproductive. When we come back, techniques to reduce friction. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
是，这不是第一次见解，人们需要大量的试错才能领悟到，无论是游泳还是骑自行车，才能开始体会到摩擦是多么关键，仅仅通过更多的施力、更多的燃料来试图提高性能是多么代价高昂。我们已经看到摩擦以不同的方式阻碍组织、社区和政府实现其目标。我们也看到，更用力地推动有时不仅无效，而且实际上适得其反。当我们回来时，将探讨减少摩擦的技术。你正在收听的是Hidden Brain。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. When prospective customers fail to buy a product or employees fail to listen to a directive or citizens fail to comply with a law. Marketers, managers and policymakers often focus on selling their message harder. If carrots fail, they bring out sticks. At Northwestern University, Lauren Nordgren and David Schonthel say there is a better way. Instead of selling harder, make it easier for the people
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。当潜在客户未能购买产品，或者员工未能听从指令，或者公民未能遵守法律时。营销人员、经理和政策制定者经常把重点放在更用力地推销他们的信息上。如果胡萝卜不管用，他们就会拿出大棒。在西北大学，劳伦·诺德格伦和大卫·舍恩菲尔德表示，有更好的方法。与其更用力地推销，不如让
who are trying to convince to buy what you are selling. Fight the frictions that hold them back. Lauren, one of the first forms of friction we discussed was a desire to follow the path of least resistance. Many years ago, psychologists were asked to help boost the number of people getting tetanous shots. They tried the idea of selling the value of the shots, being more persuasive, adding fuel, but only 3% of people bought that message and got the shot. But they also tried
你试图说服的人更容易购买你所卖的东西。对抗阻碍他们的摩擦。劳伦，我们讨论的第一种摩擦形式是渴望遵循阻力最小的路径。许多年前，心理学家被邀请帮助提高接种破伤风疫苗的人数。他们尝试了推销疫苗价值的想法，变得更具说服力，增加燃料，但只有3%的人接受了该信息并接种了疫苗。但他们也尝试了
something else that boosted that number to 28%. What did they do? that number to 28%. What did they do? They simply asked people to mark down in their calendar when they are going to get the shot and gave them a map of the inoculation center. And what do you think that is showing us, the fact that in some ways they did these very simple logistical things that help people with the logistics of the decision rather than trying to persuade them that in fact it was the right decision. What it is doing is simply making the action easier. So one dimension of effort is simply the complexity of performing the task. Writing it in a calendar makes it easier to remember.
其他东西，使这个数字上升到28%。他们做了什么？那个数字提高到28%。他们做了什么？他们只是让人们在日历上记下他们什么时候去打针，并给了他们一张接种中心的地图。你认为这向我们展示了什么，事实上，他们在某种程度上做了这些非常简单的后勤工作，帮助人们处理决定的后勤工作，而不是试图说服他们这实际上是正确的决定。它所做的只是让行动变得更容易。因此，努力的一个维度仅仅是执行任务的复杂性。把它写在日历上更容易记住。
A big reason why people don't go to checkups they intend to go to is not because they don't see the value in it, is simply because life gets complicated. Helping people find the window of opportunity to give them a roadmap for performing the behavior you want, is often the most important step in creating the behavior we want. When Netflix automatically plays the next episode of a TV series, it's reducing the tiny friction of requiring you to say,
人们不去他们打算去的体检的一个主要原因，不是因为他们看不到其中的价值，而只是因为生活变得复杂了。帮助人们找到机会之窗，为他们提供执行你想要的行为什么路线图，通常是创造我们想要的行为的最重要一步。当Netflix自动播放电视剧的下一集时，它减少了要求你说的微小摩擦，
you want to watch the next episode. The result? A lot more streaming. A lot more binge watching. Now the reduction in friction seems trivial. How much effort does it take to pick up a remote and hit play? But Netflix and other streaming companies have found reducing this tiny friction has big effects.
你想看下一集吗？结果是什么？更多的流媒体播放。更多的刷剧。现在减少摩擦似乎微不足道。拿起遥控器并点击播放需要多少努力？但Netflix和其他流媒体公司发现，减少这种微小的摩擦会产生巨大的影响。
Lauren has found the same thing when it comes to getting his students to do something he really wants them to do, fill out course evaluations. First, it's essential that you have near a hundred percent completion to make sense of evaluations. And for years, I, my colleagues have been following
劳伦在让他的学生做他真正希望他们做的事情——填写课程评估时也发现了同样的情况。首先，你需要接近百分之百的完成率才有意义地理解评估，这至关重要。多年来，我和我的同事一直在遵循
a decidedly and now in retrospect, embarrassingly, fuel-based approach, describing the importance, looking people in the eyes, this kind of eyeball to eyeball emotional appeal, assuring them that I take it seriously and learn a lot from it. And I have found no influence technique that could get this particular student body above 75% completion rates until one day I changed a practice and now it is near universal. What I do now is simply carve out time on the final day to have people complete the form. And what I am doing in that act is simply making the thing we want easy, because I suspect they all want to fill out this form.
这是一个明确的（现在回想起来，甚至是令人尴尬的）基于“燃料”的方法，强调重要性，直视人们的眼睛，进行这种面对面的情感诉求，向他们保证我非常重视并且从中学到了很多。我没有找到任何一种影响力技术能让这个特定的学生群体的完成率超过75%，直到有一天我改变了一个做法，现在完成率几乎达到了百分之百。我现在的做法很简单，就是在最后一天专门腾出时间让大家填完表格。我这样做的目的其实只是让大家去做我们想要的事情变得更容易，因为我猜他们其实都想填这份表格。
But the moment they walk out the door, tomorrow is a better day to do it. And many of them just never complete their intended action. One of the pernicious forms of friction we discussed earlier Lauren was reactants. We often respond like small children when someone suggests something to us. Our first reaction is often to object even if it's something we might like or at least eventually like. Researchers in Germany, the Netherlands and Luxembourg once tried different methods to get
但只要他们一走出门，明天再做似乎成了更好的选择。他们中的许多人最终根本没有完成他们原本打算采取的行动。我们之前讨论过的一种有害的摩擦形式是逆反心理。当有人向我们提出建议时，我们的反应往往像小孩子一样。我们的第一反应往往是反对，即使这可能是我们喜欢甚至最终会喜欢的建议。德国、荷兰和卢森堡的研究人员曾尝试过不同的方法来让
people to quit smoking. Do you remember the study? Can you tell me what they did and what they found? Yeah, it was a very simple idea. Smokers were exposed to messages that were anti-smoking about the health risks of smoking, but they created a very simple manipulation. In one case, someone read the script to them. In another case, they read the script out loud. In that latter case, people found the ideas more persuasive than when the very same evidence and data was read to them. And what that speaks to, I think, is one of the most important ideas around creating
人们戒烟。你还记得这项研究吗？你能告诉我他们做了什么以及发现了什么吗？是的，这是一个非常简单的想法。吸烟者被要求接触反吸烟信息，了解吸烟的健康风险，但他们设计了一个非常简单的操纵方式。在一种情况下，有人向他们朗读了文稿。在另一种情况下，他们自己大声朗读了文稿。在后一种情况下，人们发现这些观点比听别人向他们宣读完全相同的证据和数据更具有说服力。我认为，这说明了关于创造
change in the world. And it's the notion that we are most effectively and profoundly influenced not by ideas and data and evidence that people give to us or force upon us, but rather by ideas and evidence we generate on our own. I mean, it's a remarkable study because in this case, the messages actually did come from someone else. They were not self-generated, but merely the act of reading the message as opposed to listening to the very same message change the ownership that people felt relative to the idea.
世界变革的最重要理念之一。这就是这样一个概念：我们受到最有效、最深刻的影响，往往不是来自于别人给予我们或强加给我们的观点、数据和证据，而是来自于我们自己产生的观点和证据。我的意思是，这是一个非常了不起的研究，因为在这个例子中，信息实际上确实来自于其他人。它们不是自己生成的，仅仅是阅读信息这一动作（而不是听取完全相同的信息）就改变了人们对该观点的所有权感。
Yes, ideas are also like kids, and that we always love our own more than any other. The intuitive role of the innovator is to have the idea and to push for change. A master of influence and innovation is going to understand that through some process of co-design through co-ownership, we want people to commit themselves to these ideas. Now this is easier said than done. If you want to bring about change, what Lauren is saying is you want the people you are trying to change to feel like they are the authors of that change.
是的，想法也就像孩子一样，我们总是更爱自己的孩子，胜过爱任何别人的孩子。创新者的直观角色是提出想法并推动变革。而影响力和创新的大师则会明白，通过共同设计和共同所有权的某种过程，我们希望人们能够致力于这些想法。说起来容易做起来难。如果你想带来变革，洛伦所说的是，你希望你试图改变的人觉得他们才是这场变革的缔造者。
So, how do you go about creating the conditions for self-persuasion? One fundamental feature is we need to begin a positions of alignment. What I mean by that is very often we begin conversations at the point of conflict. You and I might both recognize that we need to change practices, but what we disagree upon is how to solve this particular problem. So we begin the conversation there. That's starting at the place of misalignment. Self-persuasion begins by understanding what is our space of alignment and establishing that baseline of agreement. The second feature of self-persuasion, we need to stop telling people what to think, and instead we need to ask.
那么，你该如何着手创造自我说服的条件呢？一个基本的特征是，我们需要从对齐的立场开始。我的意思是，很多时候我们从冲突点开始对话。你和我可能都认识到我们需要改变做法，但我们的分歧在于如何解决这个特定问题。所以我们从那里开始对话。这是从不对齐的地方开始。自我说服始于理解我们的共同空间是什么，并建立这一共识基准。自我说服的第二个特征是，我们需要停止告诉别人该想什么，转而需要去询问。
An executive gave this great example. His rule of thumb is when you are in a meeting, and you disagree with someone's position or the direction the team is taking. Never give your counterarguments until you first get people to tell you they're open to what you have to say. And the way you do that is imagine you listen very closely and then ask the question, are you open to a different point of view? I see the merits of your position, but I have some concerns, are you open to a different perspective? That is what we would call a yes question,
一位高管给出了这样一个很好的例子。他的经验法则是，当你在开会时，如果你不同意某人的立场或团队采取的方向。千万不要急于给出你的反驳意见，除非你首先让别人告诉你他们愿意听取你的想法。而做到这一点的方法是，想象你非常仔细地倾听，然后提出这样一个问题：你是否愿意接受不同的观点？我看到了你立场的价值，但我有一些担忧，你是否愿意接受不同的视角？这就是我们所谓的“是”问题，
because when you ask that question to people, the vast majority of people will say yes. And simply getting people to say yes, I want to hear what you have to say. In fact, makes them more open to your point of view. One place to see how fuel and friction produce very different outcomes is in the context of interpersonal relationships like marriage. Psychologists have found, for example, that adding fuel to a relationship is a great idea. Say and do nice things, offer compliments, but it's even more important to reduce friction. Removing the
因为当你向人们提出这个问题时，绝大多数人都会说“好”。而仅仅让人们说“好，我想听听你要说什么”。事实上，这会让他们更加愿意接受你的观点。燃料和摩擦如何产生截然不同的结果的一个例子就是在人际关系（如婚姻）的语境中。例如，心理学家发现，为人际关系添加燃料是个好主意。多说和多做美好的事情，提供赞美，但减少摩擦更为重要。消除
negatives in a relationship is often far more important than increasing the positives. It is one expression of the negativity bias, the idea that negative experience carries greater weight psychologically, emotionally, than positive experience. For relationships, it's something like five to one. Good relationships is a very loose rule of thumb. They can afford the occasional negative experience, but the key point here is if you're in a relationship that's one to one, whether it's your significant other, whether it's your boss or manager, for every one nice moment, you have one negative moment. That is not a balanced experience that is experienced as a negative toxic interaction because
人际关系中的消极因素往往比增加积极因素重要得多。这是消极偏误的一种表现，即从心理和情感上讲，消极体验比积极体验具有更大的分量。对于人际关系来说，这个比例大约是五比一。良好的关系是一个非常宽泛的经验法则。它们可以承担偶尔的消极体验，但这里的关键点是，如果你处于一段一比一的关系中，无论是与你的另一半，还是与你的老板或经理，每一次美好的时刻，你都有一个消极时刻。这不是一种平衡的体验，而会被体验为一种消极的、有毒的互动，因为
negative experience carries so much weight. And it's precisely for that reason that focusing on friction can be so valuable. In other words, focusing more on the problems in a relationship, trying to reduce those elements of friction, of conflict. In some ways, that might matter more than trying to score more positive points in a relationship, not to say the positives don't matter, but that reducing the negatives might matter more than increasing the positives. Yes, it means that if you have wonderful romantic dinners and surprise and delight flowers and you create these positive interactions and moments. But then you're prone to the blowout fight. That one moment can undo so much
消极体验承载了太多的分量。正因如此，关注摩擦才显得如此宝贵。换句话说，更多地关注关系中的问题，试图减少那些摩擦、冲突的要素。在某些方面，这可能比试图在关系中争取更多积极的分数更重要，这并不是说积极因素不重要，而是说减少消极因素可能比增加积极因素更重要。是的，这意味着如果你有美妙的浪漫晚餐、惊喜和令人愉快的鲜花，并且你创造了这些积极的互动和时刻。但随后你又很容易发生爆发性争吵。那一个时刻就可以抹杀如此之多的
of these other positive experiences. And the same is true at health and happiness within organizations. When you have a toxic work culture, often the impulse is to throw rewards and perks Happy hours Inducents, that's all fuel-based thinking That does very little because until that negative experience is addressed
其他积极体验。组织中的健康和幸福也是如此。当你拥有一个有毒的工作文化时，通常的冲动是提供奖励和津贴、欢乐时光、诱导物，这全都是基于燃料的思考，这起到的作用微乎其微，因为在解决那个负面体验之前，
That positivity is worth very very little One of the ideas that you talked about right at the start, and I want to return to, is the idea that more organizations should act like ethnographers. We cannot understand what is holding us back until we take the time and trouble to see things from the points of view of our customers and clients and partners. Can you talk about this idea and the importance of applying the principles of ethnography as we go through life, Lauren? Yes. Friction, as we said, is a process of discovery. It requires understanding the needs of the people that we are trying to serve. And the better insight we have, the better position we are to understand and remove the frictions that hold people back.
这种积极性几乎毫无价值。你在刚开始时谈到的一个我想回归的概念是，更多的组织应该像民族志学者一样行事。如果我们不花时间和精力从客户、顾客和合作伙伴的角度来看待事物，我们就无法理解是什么在阻碍我们。洛伦，你能谈谈这个想法以及在我们度过一生时应用民族志原则的重要性吗？是的。正如我们所说，摩擦是一个发现的过程。它需要理解我们试图服务的人们的需求。我们拥有的洞察力越好，我们就越能处于有利地位去理解和消除阻碍人们前进的摩擦。
And there are different ways to achieve that level of insight and perspective. One can be talk to people, and when you're talking to people, the best question is a simple one. it's simply asking why. And you might ask it more than once, because often it takes a while to really understand the true issue holding people back. And another interesting technique is to bring the people you are attempting to serve into the process, because now you can better understand your idea or innovation through their lens, through your perspective because you have them in the room with you. I'm wondering, Lauren, you've done all this thinking and work about the roles of fuel and friction. Have you applied this in your own life? Do you find yourself, you know, applying
有不同的方法来达到那种洞察力和视角水平。其中一种方法可以是与人交谈，而当你与人交谈时，最好的问题很简单。那就是简单地问为什么。你甚至可能会问不止一次，因为通常需要一段时间才能真正理解阻碍人们的真正问题。另一个有趣的技巧是将你试图服务的人带入这个过程中，因为现在你可以通过他们的镜头、通过你的视角更好地理解你的想法或创新，因为你让他们和你同在一个房间里。洛伦，我在想，你对燃料和摩擦的作用进行了所有的思考和工作。你将这些应用到你自己的生活中了吗？你发现自己，你知道，在应用
fuel to solve a problem and stopping yourself and saying, let me try and understand the source of the friction. Yes, absolutely. So one example that immediately comes to mind is my life-long effort to convince my father to buy a mobile phone. So my father's in his mid-90s, he fought in World War II, fascinating guy, and still active, despite his age, still takes walks in the woods, is quite independent.
燃料来解决问题时会停下来并对自己说：“让我试着理解摩擦的来源”吗？是的，完全是这样。所以一个立刻浮现在我脑海中的例子是我一生中试图说服我父亲买一部手机的努力。我父亲九十多岁了，他在二战中服役，是个迷人的人，尽管上了年纪，但依然充满活力，仍然在树林里散步，相当独立。
But because of that independence and living alone, I worry a lot about him, and I and the rest of the family would feel a whole lot better if he had a communication device that is hip. Fortunately, he tracks all societal ill to the innovation of the cell phone. And for years, I've been using all the influence persuasion nudge techniques to try and convince him to get a cell phone, but he is a classic resistor.
但正是因为这种独立性和独居生活，我很为他担心，我和家里的其他人如果他有一个随身携带的通信设备，感觉会好得多。幸运的是，他将所有社会弊病都归咎于手机的发明。多年来，我一直在使用所有的影响、说服、助推技术来试图说服他买一部手机，但他是一个典型的抵抗者。
And I suspect all of those techniques simply pushed him further along the path. I would love to be able to say I have now succeeded in that effort, but I haven't, because now there is such deep suspicion and resistance time I even broached the subject. But if I were to start over, if I hadn't so effectively solidified his anti-mobile phone views with all of my pushing and reactants, I might say something like, so dad, a friend of mine is trying to find the right phone
我怀疑所有这些技术只会把他沿着这条路进一步推开。我很乐意说我现在已经在那项努力中取得了成功，但我没有，因为现在每次我只要一提起这个话题，就会有如此深厚的怀疑和抵抗。但如果我要重新开始，如果我没有通过我所有的推搡和逆反心理如此有效地巩固了他对手机的反感观点，我可能会说这样的话：爸爸，我的一个朋友正试图为他的祖母找一部合适的手机
for his grandmother and she's about your age. Would you be willing to come with me and look at phones? I'd like to see which ones seem better for her. And what I'm attempting to do in that process is not to push him down this path, but to create an environment and room for him to begin to discover this technology on his own. That's one way you could move from reactants to say self-presuasion. Lauren Nordgren is a psychologist at Northwestern University. Along with David Chonthel, he's the author of the book, The Human Element, overcoming the resistance that awaits new ideas. Lauren, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so very much, this has been delightful. So very much this has been delightful.
而她大概和你同龄。你愿意跟我一起去看看手机吗？我想看看哪一款对她来说似乎更好。我在那个过程中试图做的不是把他推向这条路，而是创造一个环境和空间，让他开始自己去发现这项技术。这是你可以从逆反心理转变为自我说服的一种方法。洛伦·诺德格伦是西北大学的心理学家。他与大卫·钱特尔一起，是《人性要素：克服新想法所面临的阻力》一书的作者。洛伦，谢谢你今天做客“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢你，这太令人愉快了。非常感谢你，这太令人愉快了。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McArthei, Annie Murphy-Paul, Laura Correll, Kristen Wong, Autumn Barnes, Ryan Katz, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's Executive Editor. Our unsung heroes today are Jimmy Hart and Ty Hyman. Jimmy and Ty are sales engineers at Sweetwater, a company that sells equipment and software for musicians and producers. Whenever we reach out, they respond quickly and helpfully. As Laura Nordgren might say, they reduce all the frictions that might get in the way of our work. As an added bonus, they are delighted to work with. Thank you, Jimmy and Ty.
《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McArthei）、安妮·墨菲-保尔（Annie Murphy-Paul）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）和安德ルー·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们今天的无名英雄是吉米·哈特（Jimmy Hart）和泰·海曼（Ty Hyman）。吉米和泰是 Sweetwater 的销售工程师，该公司是一家为音乐家和制作人销售设备和软件的公司。每当我们联系他们时，他们都会迅速而有帮助地做出回应。正如劳拉·诺德格伦可能会说的那样，他们减少了所有可能阻碍我们工作的摩擦。作为一个额外的奖励，与他们合作非常令人愉快。谢谢你们，吉米和泰。
Coming up next week on our success 2.0 series, the psychology of self-doubt. How to cope with nagging feelings of insecurity, and even make them an ally. We don't acknowledge accomplishments to the extent that they should be acknowledged, and so we sometimes just minimize them. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下周我们的“成功 2.0”系列节目将播出：自我怀疑的心理学。如何应对恼人的不安全感，甚至将其转化为盟友。我们对成就的认可程度远不如应有的程度，因此我们有时只是将其最小化。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantan）。再见。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。